en esta ocasión daré una presentación
sobre lo que es el centro de masa y el
centro de masa es algo que espero te
resulte al menos un poco intuitivo y que
de hecho tiene unas aplicaciones muy
interesantes en términos muy pero muy
simples el centro de masa simplemente
pues es un punto y de hecho voy a
dibujar un objeto para que sea mucho más
claro qué es lo que voy a querer decir
con respecto al centro de masa así que
digamos que tengo esta barra no sé
digamos que esta barra tiene una masa de
10 kilogramos y digamos que es como una
regla de las que a lo mejor utilizas en
la escuela o llegaste a utilizar en la
escuela ahora la pregunta es cuál es el
centro de masa y tú dirás conjuntos con
justa razón oye pues primero dime qué es
el centro de masa para que yo pueda
decirte dónde está o qué es o lo que sea
esencialmente el centro de masa es un
punto que no necesariamente se encuentra
sobre este objeto y de hecho habrá
un ejemplo eventualmente en donde en
dónde
calculemos el centro de masa y veamos
que no está sobre el objeto pero ese
punto en especial es en donde vamos a
poder pretender o suponer que toda la
masa existe en ese punto es decir que
toda la masa se concentra en un único
punto por ejemplo en en este en este
caso de donde tenemos la regla podemos
suponer más o menos podemos intuir que
el centro de masa se encuentra justo en
digamos en lo que entendemos como el
centro de la regla verdad ahora bien lo
interesante de los del centro de masa es
que si imaginamos que aplicamos una
fuerza a esta regla justo sobre el
centro de masa no se digamos que sea de
10 newtons muy bien entonces esta fuerza
provoca que nuestro objeto que en este
caso es la regla acelere y de hecho
acelera igual que si le aplicáramos la
fuerza a un único punto que pesará 10
kilogramos que es lo que quiero decir
con esto
esto será equivalente si aplicamos esta
fuerza
justo en ese punto de la de la regla
será lo mismo que si lo aplicamos a un
único punto le aplicamos la misma fuerza
y digamos 10 newtons nada más que este
punto tiene una masa de 10 kilogramos
aquí en los 10 kilogramos estaban
distribuidos en toda la regla verdad
entonces lo que sabemos cuando cuando
aplicamos una fuerza a cualquier objeto
es que eso provoca una aceleración y de
hecho esa aceleración pues sabemos que
la fuerza es igual a la masa por la
aceleración así que la aceleración es la
fuerza entre la masa así que tenemos 10
newtons entre 10 kilogramos y esto me va
a provocar una aceleración de 1 metro
sobre segundo al cuadrado este diagrama
o este ejemplo que tenemos a la
izquierda si lo aplicamos a este punto
sería lo mismo que si aplicamos esta
fuerza a este punto de 10 kilogramos ese
punto se va a empezar a mover hacia
arriba con una aceleración de 1 metro
sobre segundo al cuadrado entonces
porque resulta útil todo esto del centro
de masa esencialmente es porque si
queremos saber cómo se comporta un
objeto que a lo mejor pueda
tener una geometría muy loca lo mejor no
sé este tiene muchos picos no es digamos
un polígono lo que sé yo entonces uno
podría encontrar el centro de masa y
predecir cómo se va a comportar sin
siquiera tener que estudiar a todo el
objeto completo ahora te voy a decir una
forma muy fácil de cómo hallar el centro
de masa ok y si tenemos un objeto que es
uniforme es decir estamos pensando en en
un objeto que que digamos para fines de
simplicidad podemos pensar que está
hecho de un único material que ese
material material es bastante homogéneo
y que digamos esté en cada punto la
densidad de ese objeto es la misma es
decir tiene la misma masa casi por
unidad por unidad de área o de volumen
dependiendo de lo que estemos hablando
verdad entonces
esto será igual el centro de masa será
igual a lo que entendemos como el centro
geométrico por ejemplo si nosotros
tenemos aquí un triángulo
déjenme pintar un triángulo
ok más o menos ahí tenemos un triángulo
entonces si este triángulo no se está
hecho de algún material y es uniforme y
homogéneo entonces a lo mejor el centro
de masa pues encontrará no sé más o
menos como por aquí que es como el
centro geométrico verdad o por ejemplo
si nosotros tenemos un cuadrado
ok
más o menos se ve como que es un
cuadrado pero ahora si suponemos que no
es uniforme digamos no sé a lo mejor la
primera mitad o la mitad de la derecha
está hecho de algún material como no sea
algún material pesado quizás es plomo
qué sé yo y digamos que la otra mitad
está hecho de no ser alguna espuma de
poliestireno algún material interesante
en construcción que se yo digamos que
está hecho de algún otro material que
tiene una densidad mucho menor que el
plomo ok entonces aquí nuestro objeto
nuestro cuadrado no es homogéneo y
entonces el poel el centro de masa no se
encontrará justo en el centro del
cuadrado sino estará ligera no bueno no
sé qué tan ligeramente o que tanto se
mueva a la derecha pero se mueve a la
derecha debido a que hay mayor
concentración digamos de masa del lado
derecho aunque entonces estará más cerca
del lado derecho porque este objeto no
es uniforme
ahora vamos a platicar de algo un
poquito más interesante porque todo lo
que hemos hecho hasta este momento en
los vídeos anteriores es suponer que
cuando aplicamos alguna fuerza esta
fuerza actúa en el centro de masa y eso
lo hacemos para poder suponer que
estamos trabajando con puntos verdad
pero por ejemplo imaginemos que no
tenemos un punto si no no sé a lo mejor
tenemos algún alguna especie de animal
no sé que esté aquí estoy pintando
alguna especie de caballo o no sé que
sea esto algún soy muy malo para dibujar
animales pero bueno digamos que aquí
tenemos este animalito y digamos que su
centro de masa se encuentra más o menos
por aquí entonces si nosotros aplicamos
una fuerza sobre ese punto todo este
este animalito se va a empezar a
acelerar de la misma forma que si
aplicamos la fuerza a un único punto
verdad donde ese punto te debería
tenerla
de nuestro caballo nuestro animal verdad
estos esto se vuelve bastante
interesante si si esta fuerza no actuara
sobre el centro de masa por ejemplo no
no sé por qué puso un caballo en
realizar podría haber seguido con el
ejemplo de la regla pero imaginen que
tenemos nuestra regla de hace un rato
que tiene una masa de 10 kilogramos y de
hecho su centro de masa tiene es bueno
se encuentra justo aquí en donde está el
centro geométrico verdad si nosotros
aplicamos una fuerza digamos que no esté
que no esté aplicándose justo al centro
de masa entonces tú ya seguramente vas a
estar incluyendo que es lo que va a
pasar verdad y esto seguro ya lo has
visto en muchos otros casos lo que
ocurre es que todo el objeto empieza a
rotar
empieza a rotar alrededor del centro de
masa verdad empieza a rotar alrededor
del centro de masa y tú ya lo has visto
por ejemplo por ejemplo puedes
imaginarte que a lo mejor tienes a
alguien enfrente y le lanzas una llave
inglesa no sé por qué se le lanzaría es
una llave inglesa de hecho te recomiendo
que no lo hagas porque le puedes
lastimar a alguien pero cuando uno lanza
la llave inglesa aunque si va avanzando
la llave esta llave empieza a girar y
gira alrededor de su centro de masa lo
mismo pasa por ejemplo con estas
personas que lanzan cuchillos en algunos
espectáculos de circo por ejemplo los
cuchillos empiezan a girar alrededor de
su centro de masa mientras van avanzando
ok y de hecho ya que hemos platicado
tanto del centro de masa ahora vamos a
hablar un poco del centro de masa y de
su importancia en aplicaciones de la
vida diaria como por ejemplo son los
saltos de altura
digamos que tenemos aquí a un
un atleta que digamos aquí está un
atleta que está preparándose para un
salto de altura muy bien entonces aquí
está ya muy listo no se esté
está muy concentrado y digamos que aquí
tenemos una barra muy alta ok entonces
aquí tenemos una barra muy alta y este
personaje quiere saltar lo y llegar al
otro lado verdad entonces uno de hecho
si uno encontrará el centro de masa uno
de hecho puede la mayoría de la gente
tiene en su centro de masa quien digamos
a la altura del ombligo y si nosotros
quisiéramos lograr que este personaje
salte del otro lado entonces uno podría
pensarlo como un movimiento de
proyectiles verdad y ya hemos estudiado
en otros vídeos movimiento de
proyectiles el punto sería que nuestro
centro de masa logre saltar la barra ok
necesitamos que el centro de masa se
mueva como un proyectil y con la segunda
ley de newton
bueno en general las leyes de newton
podríamos intentar ver como como tendría
que saltar este personaje para llegar al
otro lado al otro lado sin embargo todos
los atletas hacen un movimiento
muy raro y te invito a que a lo mejor
busques
en algún vídeo en internet en donde veas
cómo estos atletas hacen algo así hacen
como algo así
algo así aquí tienen su cabeza y sus
piernas hacen algo así como que estos
atletas se doblan verdad y en realidad
es que si se están doblando lo que
ocurre es que el centro de masa de este
de este amigo ya no se encuentra en el
zoom digamos en su vientre sino el
centro de masa en que se baja se
encuentra más abajo y no está sobre él
entonces qué es lo que ocurre que
necesitamos mucha menor fuerza para
lograr cruzar ya que el centro de masa
se encuentra mucho más abajo idea y así
necesitamos menor fuerza si es que nos
salteamos de esta forma chistosa digamos
y esta es la razón por la que los
atletas se arquean y así su centro de
masa digamos por propiedades geométricas
baja por ahora así que por debajo de la
barra espero que esto te haya resultado
muy útil vamos a seguir trabajando con
este tipo de cosas pero eso ya lo
haremos en el próximo vídeo